[Música]
bueno bienvenidos amigos como están todo
bien cómo andan
bueno qué pasa con los sueños los sueños
no se cumplen los sueños no se cumplen
los sueños no se cumplen los sueños no
se cumplen yo sé que el que está acá
sentado a todos ustedes están como
preguntándose ahora pero qué les pasa
este tipo cómo va a arrancar una charla
ted que se supone que tiene que ser
positiva aportar algo como arrancar
diciendo los sueños no se cumplen
si parece un título raro al que le puse
mi charla pero así va a ser y los
próximos minutos van a entender a qué me
refiero van a entender absolutamente
todo así que quédense acá escuchando
bueno antes que nada me presento mi
nombre entero es lucas castle nuevo en
más que nada me conocen como lukas
castle porque el apellido desde la
escuela como que no lo pronuncian bien
así que dije bueno lucas castle y así
quedó la cosa es que
estoy muy agradecido estar acá es una
charla te de la verdad que siempre quise
hacer una gracias por la oportunidad por
la audiencia por todos los que están acá
escuchando y voy a contarles brevemente
qué hago con mi vida para no aburrirlos
brevemente yo soy creador de contenidos
por así decirlo yo hago contenido en
internet hago vídeos o imágenes
cuento con un público al cual me gusta
entretener y siempre voy enfocado mucho
para lo de la comedia pero sin embargo
siempre como que me gusta dar mi punto
de vista dar consejos porque a mí me
pasan cosas yo soy una persona como
cualquier otra y esas cosas que a mí me
van pasando yo lo tomo como enseñanza y
sé que al aconsejar a la gente que me
sigue eso le puede servir porque yo
aprendo de ustedes aprenden y es como
que todos aprendemos juntos y eso está
buenísimo bueno a lo largo del tiempo
que fui creando contenidos
yo fui digamos que aprendiendo muchas
cosas porque esto no es que yo digo ah
bueno de la noche a la mañana empiezo a
subir cosas a internet y listo ya está
funciona
el primer tiempo fueron dos años que yo
empecé con los vídeos porque como que
nos motivaron en la escuela mis amigos
me decían che lucas vos tenés que hacer
vídeos pero decían como que porque yo
siempre hacía cosas en el curso hacía
reír a los demás y me decían que podría
funcionar empecé y los primeros dos años
no me miraba nadie y realmente me con
suerte de mirar a mi abuela y bueno como
que cualquiera puede decir bueno dos
años que te mira solamente tu abuela tu
mamá tus primos porque los seguís
haciendo bueno porque me gustaba lo que
hacía yo aprendía la cámara si algo me
tomaba el tiempo encontrar los momentos
en los que tenía tiempo libre porque
entre la escuela y todas las entidades
que hacían no tenía tiempo así que en
ese tiempo libre yo grababa después me
ponía a editar aprendí todo por internet
lo que sedición y todo y lo fui haciendo
bueno después dos años empezó a seguirme
a mucha gente y yo no lo podía crear
decía qué está pasando si llega a la
escuela veía que los números crecían y
yo no entendía por qué pero la cosa es
que con el tiempo comenzó esto que les
digo un crecimiento un crecimiento que
al día de hoy son casi cuatro millones
de seguidores en mi canal de youtube
con un millón y medio en instagram y en
total son 380 millones de reproducciones
en mi canal que yo sé que cuando uno
nombra los números es como raro porque
no puedes dimensionar eso no puedes
tener una manera juntar a toda esa gente
en un lugar pero no sé cómo que uno los
ve en internet y parece algo a lo que
uno está acostumbrado y es rarísimo
y qué pasó a lo largo de este tiempo a
lo largo de este tiempo fui teniendo
oportunidades gracias a estos internet
es como que se me fueran abriendo muchas
puertas y las oportunidades que se me
fueron dando como hoy estoy acá en una
charla de una que se me dio de las
charlas ted es súper importante pero qué
pasó con esto conocí mucha gente uno va
conociendo gente ahora llega acá esquel
y me saludan y estoy conociendo gente
nueva
bueno a lo largo de este tiempo que uno
conoce gente uno como que empieza a ver
a ver gente buena gente amable gente
mala gente tóxica gente que no sea uno
lo tratan mal aire todo no y con esto de
que uno conoce gente yo aprendí quiero
expresarles lo que lo que fui
aprendiendo porque capaz a ustedes les
sirve y eso sería genial
bueno al principio como le decía fue
difícil de hecho se burlaban de mí en la
escuela me molestaba me decía que por
qué hacía eso en internet y como les
digo yo siempre fui fiel a lo que me
gustaba nunca dejé de hacerlo porque de
eso se trata no importa que haya gente
que te diga que lo que hace es que no sé
no está bueno porque siempre hay esa
crítica y uno tiene que aprender a
enfocarse en sus sueños porque para qué
vas a perder tiempo en escuchar a los
demás no hay que enfocarse en uno y si
uno quiere seguir sus metas lo tienen
que hacer ahora les voy a hablar de esto
vamos a hacer un viaje todos juntos a
nuestra infancia vamos a viajar todos
juntos vamos a dejar ese momento en el
que nuestra única preocupación era
levantarnos no sea un horario en el que
teníamos que ver un dibujito que nos
recopa y le decíamos a nuestra mamá no
sea quien sea que levantarme me tengo
que ver ese dibujo también no sé la
única preocupación porque a mí me
preocupaba es a donde la chiquito llenar
un álbum de figuritas y era re
frustrante porque te tocan todas
repetidas y era así no eran las
preocupaciones de cuando bueno de buenos
chiquititos
y algo que está buenísimo a esa edad es
que uno tiene una mente impresionante
uno tiene una mente que no hay límite es
la imaginación que uno tiene no hay
límites y esta es la cabeza de que sos
tan chico sos un ser nuevo que está en
este mundo que vos decís cualquier cosa
se puede lograr
o sea tener sueños se te ocurren cosas
es obvio que se puede yo cuando era
chiquito siempre tenía la idea y hasta
soñaba de que se podía volar yo pensaba
que si salía al patio a mi casa y
agitaba muy fuerte los brazos algún día
iba a volar porque yo decía que no se va
a poder obvio que se puede si voy a
agitar los brazos voy a poder volar y
eso es lo que pasa cuando estos chicos
uno tiene mucha imaginación y esta
imaginación y como que uno no sabe bien
las cosas como que uno tiene dudas dudas
porque el cielo es azul porque no puede
respirar el agua porque el perro no te
habla a mí me molestaba mucho yo no me
hablaban pero bueno uno tiene esas dudas
y uno es tan chicos como les digo tiene
una imaginación tan amplia que uno
cuando crece cuando va creciendo pierde
un poco de eso o la totalidad de esa
libertad de la mente de que uno puede
todo se va perdiendo y por qué
se va perdiendo porque una choca con una
realidad y esa realidad con la que uno
choca es la gente que no va conociendo
gente que te puede tirar una negatividad
fuertísima que es como estar en un
invierno en el patio de tu casa con
viento y que tienen un balde agua fría
la espalda o sea se sufre así es
tremendo porque uno está con la idea de
yo quiero hacer esto y vas a empezar a
conocer gente que simplemente te tiene
mala onda
no se puede ser desde tu familia en el
ámbito escolar en el trabajo en la
universidad siempre hay gente que te va
a tirar mala onda y eso sí va a existir
siempre y ustedes lo tienen que saber y
el problema esto es cuando esa gente
realmente te hace a vos que no no sigas
en lo que quieres que te desmotiva
porque yo sé que a mí me ha pasado al
principio hasta que me acostumbré o
digamos que quise cambiar esa esa cosa
de que afecte lo que digan los demás yo
como que en un momento dije no eso no
tiene que pasar y está buenísimo que
cada uno de ustedes si a ustedes les
afecta a un mal comentario ustedes les
afecta que alguien les diga algo feo
ustedes tienen que aprender a ignorar
eso ignorar es lo mejor que pueden hacer
la mejor
que tienen para la vida obviamente con
la gente mala no estamos hablando y
cuando ustedes se empiezan a ignorar
esta gente se tiene que focalizar
solamente en ustedes porque son malas
intenciones vamos con un ejemplo no ser
cantante te van a decirnos cómo vas a
ser cantante pues tenés que hacer otra
cosa para hacer lo que todo el mundo
hace no cómo vas a estar estudiando esa
carrera pero así lo mismo que tu papá
hace lo mismo que tu hermano para para
que yo sé que te gusta la carrera pero
tengo que hacer otra cosa y la gente es
así no y lo que les quiero decir es que
tenemos una sola vida no es algo súper
simple es algo que todos sabemos pero
todos tenemos una vida y hay que saber
aprovecharla porque para qué perder el
tiempo para que realmente osea que
acuérdense como les decía de la infancia
a ese momento que éramos chiquitos y que
más que un amigo te decía no bueno
puedes volar eso mentira
realmente no nosotros estamos
conscientes de que sí y eso no hay que
perderlo tenemos una sola vida y hay que
aprovecharla porque tenemos una sola
oportunidad de cumplir nuestras metas
así que hay que no hay que dejar pasar
el tiempo y hay que enfocarnos en lo que
queremos les voy a citar una frase de
una persona súper importante del mundo
del cine quizás mucho usted hayan visto
la gente más grande los que son más
jóvenes no pero tiene una saga de
películas impresionantes se llama rocky
balboa que pasa con rocky balboa rocky
balboa es una persona que no es que te
va a motivar a boxear quizás si también
te puede motivar a hacer deporte te
puede motivar a muchas cosas depende del
ángulo donde uno lo mire y por qué lo
nombré porque es una por qué es tan
exitoso él toda la saga rocky balboa
porque te enseña a la superación
personal a mí me ha servido le ha
servido muchísima gente vos ve las
películas y es imposible que nos dé
motivos y una frase que él dijo es si
sabes lo que vales ve y consigue lo que
mereces pero tendrás que aguantar los
golpes es una frase increíble
la película que en una escena la dice y
de eso se trata esa mentalidad te da que
la puedes aplicar en cualquier cosa que
quieres hacer vos podés o tenés que ir
adelante pero tienes que ser consciente
obviamente de que tienes que pasar por
muchas cosas nadie te va a decir que sea
cual sea tu meta va a ser fácil hacerlo
nunca va a ser fácil hacerlo yo que hago
cosas en internet siempre tuve que
bancarme a gente que me dice cómo hacer
cosas en internet vos sos un vago es lo
que más te dicen no porque es algo como
que es raro es algo diferente es algo
que no se acostumbra y bueno yo sigo
adelante porque me encanta lo que hago y
de eso se trata
y lo que pasa con todo esto que quiero
llegar ahora a la charla es que quiero
hablarles de lo que a mí me gusta
aplicar que me funciona muchísimo que
nunca para muchos lo vieron por internet
lo leyeron capas hay mucho que dice no
eso no sirve en la ley de atracción la
ley de atracción es algo que te puede
llevar a lograr lo que quieres y como la
aplicamos bueno les voy a contar
brevemente para no aburrirlos bueno la
cosa es así el ejemplo es de vuelta ser
cantante ok de qué se trata de esto
bueno se trata de un estilo de vida en
el que ustedes tienen que ser muy
positivos yo soy así soy muy positivo
todo el tiempo el ejemplo es el cantante
ustedes para lograr llegar a ese punto
lograr esa meta tienen que focalizar se
tienen que visualizarse ustedes mismos
logrando lo no se trata de decir ojalá
algún día logre eso no se trata de
visualizarse por ejemplo vamos por
partes
ustedes se acuestan a dormir están ahí
por dormirse y visualizan a ustedes
escribiendo las letras de las canciones
que por dónde se empieza escriben la
lista de canciones
se imaginan ahí sentados ok después se
tienen que visualizar grabando las
canciones en el estudio
y después se visualizan cuando ya
empiezan los afiches con sus caras
cuando ya entra gente a escucharlos
cantar cuando la gente canta las
canciones tienen que imaginarse las
sensaciones que tendrían en ese momento
y cuando uno se enfoca tanto empieza a
pensar de otra forma porque vos sabes lo
que quieres hacer y uno empieza a pensar
de una manera en la que no empezás a
decir quizás algún día logre capaz que
puedo ojalá no décimas eso vos tenés que
hablar confirmando los bo decís tengo
que lograr ser esto lo voy a hacer yo
puedo hacerlo tenés que empezar a hablar
de esa manera esa es la actitud que
tenés que tener frente a la vida por
pero para lograrlo tenés que saber hacer
todo lo previo no voy a confirmarlo o
sea lo que sea vamos a hablar y
confirmarlo pero para lograr eso para
llegar acá que es ser cantante tienen
que levantarse todos los días y decir ok
bueno tengo que lograr esto bueno clase
de canto ok voy con lo siguiente tienen
que prepararse tienen que hacer todo lo
que tiene que haber previos para que ese
sueño se cumpla y así lo van a lograr y
eso es increíble porque cuando ustedes
empiezan a usar la ley de atracción no
hay nada que te frene porque
cuando te pasa algo malo ni te das
cuenta porque está focalizado en las
cosas buenas la vida no te vas a dar
cuenta de algo malo solamente las cosas
buena vas a aprovechar los pequeños
detalles de la vida es increíble porque
en un punto estás tan focalizado lo
bueno que ni te das cuenta de lo malo
pero parece que todo sale a propósito
para que bojan es algo que quieres
lograr así que poco a poco esto lo vamos
a poder ir aplicando y porque la charla
se llama los sueños no se cumplen porque
es la frase que te dice la gente tóxica
a la cual son obstáculos en la vida que
hay que intentar esquivarlos para llegar
a donde queremos pero los sueños no se
cumplen es una frase que en parte me
gusta porque los sueños no se cumplen
por arte de magia no hagan eso de mirar
la estrella fugaz y ya y pedís el deseo
y listo y te quedas sentados en el
sillón de tu casa y decís bueno así que
los sueños sí se cumplen pero hay que
hacer que se cumplan no no hay que pedir
un deseo y listo hay que trabajar en
ellos ojalá la gente les haya gustado
mucho esta charla la verdad es que
espero
y aportar algo porque a mí me ha servido
y está mi forma de pensar frente a la
vida
soy lukas castle y gracias por el apoyo
[Aplausos]
gracias